thanks
good morning or good afternoon everyone
and welcome to our webinar stem cell
derived exosome production in steep tank
bioreactors
this webinar is part of our virtual
event eppendorf planet of knowledge
here on lab routes following the webinar
take your time
and have a look at our event platform
and discover more content and workflow
solutions for your research
my name is david zorbach the moderator
of today's session and now
let me introduce to you my colleagues
aurelie and hawker
who will present their work on exosome
production in steer tank bioreactors to
you
and with this i will hand over to hover
yeah thank you david uh hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar entitled
stem cells derived exosomes
production in stereotype bioreactors
uh this is the agenda we prepared for
you today
and we divide in three main topics first
i will add the introduction i will
discuss about some
as a promising cell free therapy tool
then we will discuss about the challenge
behind nexus and production process
the second process we will describe
process development
in that box mini parallel reactor system
and then
at the end i will explain the existing
production on siberia between by reactor
control system yeah
as everybody knows stem cell therapy
also known as regenerative medicine
is designed to repair damaged tissue the
human body
by implanting new other stem cells
modulating the immune system and
reducing
inflammation the promise of stem cell
uh the therapy is to help the body to
heal
itself increasing the quality of life of
life for
patients so you can see here more than
five
thousand clinical trials have been
reduced for different
applications the global essential market
is very competitive uh nowadays an
estimate to reach around 146 million
dollars
but 2024 this market is fueled to
the therapeutic action of stem cells for
certain disease treatment
and because of the stem cell line
banking
in addition to that the development in
views for important stem cells
ipsc also has contributed to the growth
of this market
due to the social ethical issues as
shared with embryonic stem cells
as you can see you can see here in the
picture of them
that disorder segment during the global
stem cell therapy
but unfortunately clinical trials uh
have
made only a modest improvement in
restoring normal functions
to the relative tissues
in the early days the mechanisms of
action of the cell therapy
claimed that cells implanted should
integrate in the site of
injury replace the damaged tissue and
improve tissue and organs
however limitations associated with cell
localization and self-survival
in the target issue works against
peaceful generation
but the real question here is do we have
the right tool
to address this to address the cell
therapy limitation
let's go through that exercise bicycles
including exosomes
are one of the most important parachain
effectors
involved in the intercellular
communication
they were discovered more than three
years ago and they were considered as
cellular west
disposals uh think of an exosome
as an embryo with instruction inside
like one cell male in a later to another
one telling me what to do
in this case the envelope that is the
exosome cargo
contain micro rna non-cooling arranged
and
a lot of proteins they are released from
difficult types uh such as tmb cells
mesenchymal stem cells steel cells
as i mentioned before they mediate inter
and intracellular communication when
they are secreted in the
stream and also they emulate the immune
regulatory processes
set up tumors k mechanisms and mediate
grenade
or the herniated process
uh they have also a round shape
morphology
and they are present in the priority of
body fluids such as blood
urine amniotic fluids synovial fluid
etc the cell sacrosome consists of
extracellular vesicles
specifically some micro vesicles
membrane particles
peptides and small proteins so you can
see
here uh uh which is this this picture
because we have
you know a comparison between them but
you know exosomes are
lipid belayers basically with the
diameter ranging between 50 and 100
nanometers and also they can easily
confirm by suffers
such as cd9 cd c3
cd81 of the transparents
yeah but not all the mesenchymal derives
and
derived exosomes are similar uh the
mesenchymal stem cells are present in
in different adult pieces such as alipon
tissue bone markers or umbilical cord
as well as pse and embryonic
stem cells and depending of the source
there is some yield
is completely different so they offer
several advantages compared to the
cell-based
approaches including exceptional
stability
and biocompatibility moreover they can
be delivered to target fisa
easier than the whole cells and they can
migrate
across the blood brand barrier
according to the pubmed and you can see
here in the slide
the number of citation has grown more
than 10 times
in the last decade or so have gaining
importance
today this new cell free therapy has had
a big
impact in various fields of application
reaching 192 clinical trials
worldwide related to episodes that are
listed
in clinicaltribe.com so they have been
used
as drug delivery systems as tumor
biomarkers
and mesenchyma extensive direct exosomes
also have great potential in bone
and calves regeneration
this figure showed the biotherapeutic
particle history since
2006 so as you can see here
in 2006 was approved the first cancer
vaccine
later in 2012 uh was approved the first
gene therapy and in 2015 was approved
first on collective biotherapy products
oh and now i will let my holy cow really
to describe the challenge
behind exosome production process
thank you jorge now you have a clear
view of what's on exosomes
and are growing interest in the context
of cell free therapy nevertheless
the exosome production process is still
challenging
and the preclinical and clinical
development of the exosome technology
as a cell free therapy or drug delivery
platforms we cry large quantity of
exosomes
it's really difficult to define a
precise range
regarding the optimal therapeutic dose
indeed this therapeutic dose will depend
on the specific purpose of the study and
on the way the exosomes are quantified
but
you have here an example of the huge
quantity of exosome which is required to
be administered to an
animal to achieve biological outcomes so
the mass production of exosomes is then
a requirement to generate a
clinically relevant amount of exosomes
however the mass production of exosomes
presents several
challenges indeed you have to reach a
delicate equilibrium between the
quantity
and the quality and the final product
must be pure
but also keep its biologic biological
property
the manufacture process you have to use
should be scalable of course but also
have to be controlled
standardized in order to improve
reproducibility
and finally this process should be in
accordance with the appropriate
regulation requirement
so for the moment the most current
methods used to enrich collect and
isolate exosomes are not fitting
with those aspects the exosome
production workflow is a multi-step
process and could be divided in three
major steps
the upstream process here first
during which the cells used as exosome
sources
are expanded and also during which the
exosomes are enriched in the cell
condition
medium the second step is the downstream
process
consisting in the isolation of the
secreted exosomes from
others element containing the condition
medium
and finally the quality control which is
based on the exosome characterization
and for all those steps um all those
steps could be a source of variability
and a challenge for the researcher and
for example for the
upstream process the question of the
researcher could be
which exosome source to select or
how to ensure an efficient cell
proliferation and exosome suppression
how to deal and how to proceed to the in
process control
so before to go more in detail with the
upstream process which is the topic
of today i would like to briefly
describe you
some challenging aspect and key message
associated with the downstream process
and the quality control
there is a large variety of techniques
which could be used to isolate it
hexosomes
historical gold standard methods are
based on ultracentrifugation
with two main variation either
differential palleting or using density
gradient but in a manufacturer point of
view
the ultrasound ultrasound certification
based methods
are present some limitation especially
because
they are difficult to scale up the
process is often long multi-step
and require high level of skill and
expensive equipment so it exists a lot
of different order techniques
to isolate exosomes such as size
exclusion chromatography
filtration-based method precipitation
or immuno affinity capture
those methods present a better
scalability but
all those methods present advantage are
a limitation
of course main uh iris
um here is some some important message
to consider from for exosome isolation
strategy
and selection especially in the
transition from a bench scale to
a clinical production of exosomes so
first of all a very important message
that
is that for the moment there is really a
lack of
standardization for the exosome
isolation strategy
nevertheless the isolation strategy you
choose with
will will greatly impact the final
product
so it's really important to keep this in
mind
another point is that often researchers
will use combined techniques
in order to improve the purity of the
final product
with a balance between recovery and
specificity and
the choose of the technique the truth of
the strategy to combine
together to to to isolate your exosomes
will really
really depend of the final purpose so
that's the
once again the question of the balance
between the recovery and the specificity
in a context of mass production of
exosomes in a therapeutic
purpose the crucial aspects to keep in
mind are of course scalability
respect of regulation potency
maintenance of the final product
process control but also specificity and
high
efficiency in terms of yield cost and
time so it's really really
challenging regarding the exosome
characterization
there is also very large variety of
method used
making results and analysis really
difficult between
difficult to compare sorry between study
from from a study to another so some
methods are based on
physical properties others are based
on the presence of specific markers
and recent review also highlight
emerging techniques
but once again there is some challenge
especially the standardization
the specificity the sensitivity and the
throughput
of those methods and now we will focus
on the first step of the workflow
so the upstream process resulting in an
efficient
exosome suppression we would like to
highlight key factors to address to
improve
and warrant a successful and
reproducible upstream process
so as jorge mentioned in the beginning
of this introduction
not all exosomes are the same not all
hemisc derived exosome are similar
during uh it's really important to keep
in mind
that the cell culture parameters used to
improve and to to process the cell
expansion
will largely impact the quantity and the
quality of the secreted
product and the secreted exosomes so any
change in the cellular phenotype due
for example to the adhesion process the
proliferation process
or to any potential uh cellular stress
occurring during this
this phase of the culture could and once
uh could generate
unwanted alteration in the composition
and the function of all those exosomes
has those two very interesting uh
interesting articles um
describe so of course
uh you could consider different
parameters which could impact it could
be the culture medium the culture
support
but also other physical chemical
parameters
regarding the culture medium
the idea is to push an efficient and
robust cell proliferation
of course to do that we usually use
growth factors generally supplement in
the medium as a
fatal bovine serum but nevertheless
those animal derived supplements contain
exogenous exosomes which could cause
contamination in the final product
so exosome collection could be then
consequently performed differently
either
either using um culture medium
supplemented with
exosome depleted fbs in order to reduce
the
the potential contamination take care
that it's not a free
of exosome medium but exosome depleted
it will just reduce the contamination
another way it's to use a two-step
process
with the first phase which is which
answer the cell expansion in a classical
culture medium
as soon as you have obtained an optimal
cell density
you will completely change the medium
for an exosome collection medium
which is free of exogenous medium in
this medium the cell will decrease the
proliferation but you will
use this medium for a reduced period of
time just to collect the exosomes
some commercial versions of those medium
exist and are supplemented to increase
the exosome succession
another important parameters is the
culture support
especially in a scale-up process so
conventional 2d adherent cell culture
support
such as flask or multi-layer flask are
limited
in terms of growth surface area per
volumes
so usually we go in the direction of the
3d culture especially based on the use
of macrocarriers to increase the cell
density
using a bioreactor and
this culture in 3d could offer
not only the advantage to be scalable
but also the advantage to be more
physiological for the cells and
different papers have has already
described the fact that
the use of a 3d culture could improve
the yield and the functionality of the
secreted exosome
in the transition for the 3d culture
there is a lot of parameters that you
have to
to optimize you know in order to ensure
a robust attachment and
an efficient start of proliferation
amongst those parameters you could of
course select
the most appropriate type of carrier the
initial cell seeding density could also
be optimized
as the cell carrier denser ratio
and you could also optimize the first
period of time
in order to improve the adhesion with a
reduced agitation for example or using a
reduced volume
finally there is a lot of different
physical chemical parameters which could
impact your culture and you have to take
care to the ph
the oxygen tension the temperature
maintenance the agitation
and of course the feeding strategy you
will use
as an example here in order to be
morphed geological you could be
interested to reduce the tension of
oxygen
in order to be more physiological
mimicking the in vivo niche of the stem
cells
and all those parameters should be
stable and more
sorry could you moot thank you
in this way the use of stereotank
bioreactors could be very interesting
and offer you a lot of uh advantage
those uh bioreactors um
[Music]
allow you to process um to monitor and
control your process
during all the entire process you could
um really control and find the ideal
condition maintain those conditions
during
all the process and nevertheless
moreover they propose a scalability
option
with a similar vessel geometry and
capability at different size
so it's very interesting in in this way
as a conclusion of this introduction
we would like to insist on the
importance of the standardization
of the entire process through all this
process from the cell culture
to the final characterization and it's
also very important
to really describe in detail the
material and method part of the
publication in order to be really
reproducible and to reproduce exactly
the same condition
in the next part of the the presentation
we will introduce you the use of the
dashbox mini
parallel bioreactor system to develop an
exosome production process in a
small-scale
tire tank bioreactor and optimize the
culture condition
before a potential scaling up
so this first slide uh described here
the experimental strategy used for the
upstream process
so mscs derived from adipose tissues
have been selected as an exosome source
after towing the cells will recover a
few days in a flask
the appropriate amount of cells have
been
seeded on microcarriers in the bioblue
single used vessels
and the cell grow is then monitored
during 5 days
by the dust box systems growth factors
are headed
3 days post seeding in order to improve
to
ensure proliferation regular monitoring
of the cell adhesion but also the cell
viability is performed during
the expansion phase after a five day of
cell growth the culture medium
has been completely changed for a
collection medium
which is free of exogenous exosomes
and the exosome enrichment occur during
two additional days at the end
before our vesting and performing
downstream process
here are the main process parameters
used during this
upstream process you have here the
type of carriers and the quantity we
have used the inoculation cell density
and the working volumes importantly we
have
note here the cell carrier ratio and the
dissolved
uh oxygen percentage which which
correspond to
a pressure of oxygen of eight percent
mimicking the in vivo environment
we have also the ph and also information
about
different parameters such as the
agitation
we have the agitation for for the first
four hours and then the agitation was
set at
100 rpm during all the process
here are the first results cell
viability was determined
regularly during the process by staining
with a fluorescent
calcine am probe and visualize
under a fluorescent microscope as you
can see through the five
days post seeding cells are growing
progressively and from progressively
small aggregates
and 3d structure the proliferation has
also be evaluated through cell counting
perform a different time point during
the process
so small samples of the cell suspension
are taken from
bioreactors and cells are detached with
trypsins
and count it with a visceral automated
cell contour
the result obtained confirmed the
efficient proliferation with a very
short
luck phase at the beginning and the
final density is note here
you have here the complete the the total
number of cells in the vessels
which and the fall increase we have
obtained after five days
in the meantime we have also checked the
concentration in glucose and
concentration in lactate
which are uh liber liberate it's created
in the
in the culture medium and those
parameters also confirm that the
proliferation is efficient
now here is the experimental process
used for the downstream part
we have collected of course the
self-conditioned medium
and this medium has been centrifuge
filtrate and
concentrate using those parameters
a small sample is
safe to perform particle size
distribution analysis
and the rest of the volumes is load on a
size exclusion chromatography colon we
collect at the n22 fraction
and the total protein content is also
evaluated
during all this process at the end
every fraction is concentrated before to
be submit to
exosome characterization and in our case
we have select
to study the the presence of the cd63
protein a transmembrane uh tetraspanning
protein which is specific of exosomes
true thanks to an elisa approach but
also with a western blood approach
negative control it's really important
was also performed
in parallel it consists in a
non-condition
medium so it's the the collection medium
without be
with no contact with the cells and this
negative control
[Music]
has follow exactly the same procedure
the same process
than our conditioned medium
here are the result obtained with the
elute fraction
uh using the elysee and the total amount
uh a pro count so in blue you have the
total amount
evalua evolution in all those fraction
and you can see that there is a peak
here on the
on the fraction 20 21 and 22.
in parallel we have also the result from
the elisa essay
and here you have seen that we have a
peak uh
on the top of the fraction 18 and 19.
with a maximum of quantity in the
fraction 19
corresponding to 9 to 10 um
exosome quantity
we confirm this those results with a
western blood analysis and here
again we have an increase of the
cd63 protein in the fraction
from 16 to 20 with the peak at the
fraction
18 and 19 17 until
uh 219.
finally we
evaluate the size distribution of the
samples we have collected
through two different methods the
dynamic light scattering and the
centrifugal liquid sedimentation
analysis
once uh those two methods confirm that
we have a population or a b model
distribution with two neural nearby
population
uh at size ranging in the the
range of the exosomes so
to conclude this part of the
presentation
we can say that the dashbox mini
reactors is a perfect tool to test and
optimize the process at small scale
you can really compare and test the
influence of different
culture parameters during all the
process it's really easy to compare
you you could monitor every physical
chemical parameters
in a very stable environment in order to
define
reproducible parameters to reproduce at
the end
so now i would like to let jorge present
another
and different strategy in order to
produce exosome in the psi barrier
in this case as you can see here we use
bioluminescence single-use
vessels as bioreactors for uh
induced important stem cells that are
mesenchyma
stem cells exosomes uh production
isolation and characterization we employ
the siberian between bioreactor control
system
as a controller device and calling
called micro carriers
as uh so crucial support so for the main
aim in this story was the production
of autosomes using one liter scale as a
model
for large scale production in
bioreactors
and to demonstrate the ability of ipsc
derived mesenchyma stem cells to create
exosomes we perform two uh median
exchange experiment
in four steps as the picture shows
yeah in the step uh number one a details
inoculation the
preparation we use typically we use
t-flash cultural conditions
for the initial expansion and hyper
flash
in the third process to achieve the
appropriate inoculation cell density
then uh the standard capacity of ipsc
derived mesenchymas themselves
was analyzed by flow cytometry noting
that
they display typical phenotype of
mesenchyma stem cells
possibly for cd90 and cd29 typical
mesenchymal stem cells market and
negative foreign metabolic markers such
as cd
34 and then for monocyte
1110
so then ips drivers in china tell us
where transfer into glass bottle
containing the
collagen called micro carriers and cell
portion medium in this case we use two
different kind of media
ns12 and 80 cc complete million
then we kept the bottles in about in the
incubator for two hours
uh under certain conditions you can see
here
yeah on the other hand prior to the
preparation
of the bioblue one c one c single used
vessel
we perform a calibration of the ph
sensor
and then we outfitted uh each blue among
others with
a d2 along with the compressed probe
adapter both inserted in the first pg
13.5 port on their aesthetic positions
i have to i would like to highlight here
that this big view
was used to do the median exchange
following the incubation um
following the incubation 300 cells of
microcarriers were transferred
into the biology once you have reactor
really filled with
100 milliliters of millions reaching the
working volt
of one liter yeah after
day uh five also cursor we perform
the median exchange every two days on
the day
nine and then daily basis as required
uh but how we did that so we stopped the
agitation
and gas flow for five minutes allowing
the micro carriers
to start in the bottom of the bio blue
one c and exchange
ten percent of the medium using uh that
dq
to remove the cell cursor medium from
the surface
and using the feeding port to add fresh
medium
yeah um after day um
five uh eight at eleven
uh uh day five eight eleven and fourteen
that's closer we collect 50 milliliters
of uh
years of ips derived mesenchyma stem
cells along with my
carriers and and and medium use a
container back
with uh line set so we transfer that 50
milliliters into
50 milliliters conical 2 uh along the
aps-c derived mesenchymal stem cells and
microcurrent
in the bottom so then we removed that
supernatant and added 50 milliliters
more
medium using the same composition but in
this case replacing the fps
with uh two percent of exosome depleted
fps and then transferred into the the
shaking class
so finally we incubate that isc drivers
and kind of stem cells
on micro carriers for 48 hours under the
same conditions
so then 48 hours after e-collection day
as you can see here in this
slide and
we removed the super name and then uh we
performed the isolation purification
of exosomes according to the exocrys pc
protocol with some modifications you can
see here
so we collected samples every day
in the course of the first experiment
and every two days in the second
experiment from bioreactors
to determine the cell viability
cell density and metabolite
concentration
so three milliliters were collected for
analysis then
this uh a volume will transfer and into
the conical field
so we wash with pbs and then we
directionalize the cells
in order to detach the sauce from the
micro carriers
and do the the analysis
so later on the cells uh a microcurrent
work filter through
a 40 micron strainer in order to
determine determining the same viability
and density as you can see here in the
picture
after the cell expansion the cell count
was erratic
especially after each collection day so
we attribute this
to the low inosilation density and also
because we're using the first experiment
the demand f12
cell cursor median whose composition
probably won't be
so optimal for the ipsc derived
mesenchymal stem cells
expansion um
also we performed a second experiment to
increase the ipsc derived mesenchyma
stem cells inoculation density
and the exosome production yield for
each sample so to achieve that we change
the third question media
in this case uh we use apc complete
median
uh and also we increase the inoculation
cell
density finally we kept the rest of the
conditions
in the assays out of the first
expression
you can see uh in picture a uh we all
said
uh uh observed and it shall lag phase 24
hours after the inoculation
followed by the steady increase of cell
growth between
day one and day and day night so then
the closer reached the stationary phase
on day night
followed by a subsequent decrease in the
cell density
until day 15. i have to to add here that
we observe as essential microcarrier
segregation
later in the course of the run therefore
we base the cell count in the later
stage not only to the floating
microcurrent
only in the to the floating market
carriage so probably the average of the
cell expansion direction
must be higher in addition
so we determine the consumption of
glucose production of lactate
and ammonia as you can see here in the
pictures
exosomes are highly enriched in protein
in the transparent membrane as i
mentioned before cd
63 9 81 and 82
play a key role in cell invasion
penetration
and solutions evidence so we use the
direct
enzyme link immuno assays
elisa specifically elijah ultra c
63 kid in order to quantify the exosome
abundance the results showed that the
number of ipsc dramas and chima
stem cells exosome constantly increased
from day 5
to day 16. so in addition so also we
found
a direct correlation between cell
density and secreted exosomes
during the experiment
it's only the three dimensional
dimensions of some more four wheel
probably including micro carriers
we collect samples at the five and nine
as you can see here
in the picture and then visualize them
through the bright field images
so we evaluate the portfolio of human
ips derivements and
stem cells demonstrating that as you can
see uh
in in the picture on the left side at
the early stage of the cell
profile a few cells are done on the
microcurrent surface
are progressively formed inter micro
carrier
uh cellular bridge and aggregates as you
can see
so it's well known that the 3ds
sterile environment allowed the cells to
mimic the imbue several behavior
involving cell cell and cell
extracellular matrix
interaction and promoted cell signaling
and proliferation so it has recently
been reported that although the
mechanism
of exosome biogenesis is so
well understood finding suggests that
the exosome segregation
a molecular cargo can be altered by the
cells
microenvironments it's important to see
to study morphology
so finally i would like to to add that
these
various training experiments are
preliminary studies
it has not just been optimized to obtain
the maximum exercise on production
levels
however our observations can serve as a
guideline
for further improvement in missing
camera stem cells that are exercising
isolation
purification and skill of protocol
thank you very much
thank you already and jorge for the
presentation
for everyone if you haven't done yet
there's still time to submit your
questions via the q a window to give you
a little bit time to do this
i would like to show you in more detail
three of our products
that we used for these studies
first there's the selexpert co2
incubator
you do not need to worry anymore to
place your plates always at the exact
same position
because with our incubator we verified
the uniform temperature throughout the
whole system
at 27 different spots so we really
ensure that there is a homogeneous
growth condition
the second one um aurelie talked quite
extensive about was the dustbox mini
bioreactor
system this is a perfect system that
simplifies your process development
it's a four-fold unit but it can be
extended up to 24 bioreactors
and together with a possibility to
easily integrate third-party analyzers
and the combination with our powerful
dustwear software suit
the dust box is the perfect tool for the
efficient process development
and last the saverio twin our newest
bioprocess family member
from the experiments and the results
that hoha did present
the twin controller already supports 19
different vessel variants
and there will be even more to come in
the future
the innovative pay draw concept of this
system allows you to be
to easily adjust it for changing
requirements in the lab
if you want to have more information on
this product
you just visit our website
eppendorf.comaria
i see now that there are a couple of
questions so
i was to start reading with the first
one and this is
going to hover if i see it correct
the question is how do you ensure that
you do not have exosomes from the growth
media in your experiments
oh thank you david this is a good
question
uh well a critical app here has to be
considered
before exosome production and uh
essentially is the cell culture
and we had before
when we were designing this experiment
we
we certainly performed several
preliminary studies to establish
the best conditions you know so one of
them determine the medium composition
so we use medium without fbs medium with
with different
exercise fbs finally we found that two
percent
uh er exercises sufficient
to monitor the ground
but you know this is one thing that uh
we
have we have to see in the future we
need more developments of course
uh in order to uh do it for this kind of
applications
okay thank you the second question is
focusing um yeah is for overlea
why are mesenchymal stem cells a common
cell type used in clinical trials to
generate extracellular vesicles
since a few years um we know that the
msc secretary
paraquin factors secreted by hemis
are described to play a very important
role and have biological outcomes
it could be cytokine chemokines growth
factors but also
evs including microcarriers
including three exosomes and
ev derived from mesenchymal stem cells
have been described to have a
different potential interesting effect
such as increasing androgenesis and
wound
repair reduce myocardial
ischemia reperfusion injury
promotes a large variety of tissue
regeneration so
that could be the reason why the msc
thank you overly the next question is
for hawker again
have you compared the results obtained
by eliza with other quantification
methods
uh yes thank you david so yeah we used
three different methods like the
exosomes
in the berlin we use the micro
the ca holding aside to
the total concentration and after after
combination
realized
because this
asset gave us better results and logical
exercise
production training
okay i hope everyone could understand
this and the audio of connection is not
too bad
the next question the next question is
also for
why did you use ipsc derived mscs and no
other ms
sources okay this is a good question so
as i mentioned before one of the
preliminary story
that we did was was the selection of the
cell source
so it we did three studies in parallel
uh using adipose derivements and climate
stem cells
bone marrow stromal cells and ipsc the
right mason timer stem cell
but what we saw in in this experiment is
that
using the ipsc i was able to get
the highest yield of exercise uh under
our specific conditions so but it's good
that
you know this is a good example for our
customers so
we were we were not pursuing a
particular
sales source we were able to use one and
show the customers that
with our conditions they can get a good
amount of exercise and also they can
follow
our protocols
okay great uh is there a solution to
just harvest the supernatant with the
exosomes
already uh that one is for you okay
um i would say that usually for the
secrete cell derived product
we could use fibrous cell disk and
packed bed bioreactors which offer a
nice opportunity to make easier
the collection of the final product but
with
exosomes it's there is some some
difficulties
related to the medium composition and
the presence of the exogenous exosomes
in the medium
as we have mentioned in the first
question um
and so as previously discussed there is
no perfect composition for the moment
to promote in the meantime the cell
proliferation
very efficiently without exogenous
ev contamination so we have to shift
switch the medium for ev collection
medium which is not so easy
with the packed bed by reactors
and which isolation system do you see
best suited for
the future to scale up the process
if i could continue perhaps i could say
that currently
there is no perfect and standard
isolation methods
usually researchers use a combination of
two techniques
to improve the purity and reach the
balance between
specificity and
efficiency an interesting combination in
terms of scale-ups could be
the use of the tangential flow
filtration first
followed by a more specific affinity
capture
step
yeah if i can say something that there
is no standardized method that we can
use
right now in the market so the best
thing that we can do is to combine both
in order to get the high peers of
populations
okay thank you um the next question
i guess both of you can answer or i have
a different answer it's uh which
microcarrier did you use for your
experiment
uh yeah perhaps i can start um
it exists really a large variety of
different carriers on the market
and on the publication there is no
a perfect solution for msc so there is
large different possibilities some
carriers could be macroporous
microporous
non-porous some present some surface
coating
such as collagen or synthemax coated
carrier to improve the cell adhesion so
it's not so easy to select
um i think it depends on the cell type
you use
but also on the medium composition
for example when you use synthetic
medium or
medium which are reduced in fps you
could
you could use surface coated
carriers in order to improve the cell
initial
adhesion on the carriers so what that's
what we have done
for uh my part of the the
experiment and we have used the syntemx
coated carriers
yeah so i use the golden gold color so
they're good uh
in self-support at the beginning of the
of experiment when
we need the discuss attached as soon as
possible
over the surface and
avoid lag in our in our culture so and
with the coloring code cars are good
microcurrents to
address uh and to avoid certain
limitations of cell
cell attachment at the beginning of the
spring
okay uh at the beginning of the
presentation you mentioned the
increasing
interest and clinical treatments can you
give an example of oxygen used in
clinical treatment
well um so when i was
of course my preliminary studies the the
story that had been done
and then preparing this uh webinar so i
have been
reviewing of course a lot of literature
but then i found
you know right now as as everybody saw
in the presentation that there are many
products in the market and many many
clinical trials going on
right now but i would like to highlight
one paper
um the paper
is from professor gable and collaborator
from the university of essen
in in germany and they use
mesenchyma stem cells derivation as a
novel tool to trade therapy refractory
graft versus host
tissue uh because mesenchymal
stem cells are considered
immunomodulating
uh cells i mean this this is for the
people who are not
very familiar with with that is when you
implant
uh a tissue from one person
and then uh the the the the hospice will
reject this uh
allergenic cells that are implanted in
in this patient
normally what people use is corticoids
in order to reduce inflammation
a lot of the immune system to accept the
the new cells
but basically they have been they use
here exosomes with good results i
i mean if people want to read more
information about that i would be happy
to share the
paper but basically at the end they
found that they've reviews
the colorado side reactions uh
due to that disease and yeah they
explained that
they did that in one patient and they
found good
uh you know they conclude that the
exosomes
may be a great potential to to to reduce
inflammation
as a sky disease i think this is one
example but again
right now we have many options in the
market many clinical trials going on
this is a new field
and i have hope that uh many limitations
associated with the cell therapy can be
addressed
using the exosomes uh or cell free
therapy as
uh people know uh this field right
now
there are really a lot of questions on
the list but i think we have time for
one last question
only i will give this one to you how to
reduce the leg
phase often observed after seeding in a
bioreactor
all right it's a good question um
especially for people which are
perhaps afraid by the transition from 2d
to 3d
culture so of course
the the the quality of the
initial cell is very important
you have of course to use self uh
very young the successive passage
especially for mscs could induce
progressive senescence and changing the
phenotype and decreasing the
proliferation
rate um the carrier selection is also
important
uh you have we have already discussed
this point
uh but also other parameters like the
initial self-seeding density
and the so-called cell to beat ratio
so it's really important to to optimize
those parameters
with your system usually we use a ratio
of
three to five cells per beat
it's recommended but you you have to
optimize this case by case
and test with yourself and your medium
um another recommendation could be
to to really stop the agitation during
the first
hours just after the feeding of the
cells and work also with the reduce
working volumes during this short period
period
it could help the addition of the cells
to the to the carriers and then
a better start of the proliferation a
faster start
um this is an interesting parameters
uh yeah
okay thank you both for all the detailed
answers for all the questions
that we didn't answer yet uh we will get
in contact with you soon
and write you an email with an answer to
your questions
thank you all for listening and enjoy
the rest of the day
bye